ciao ragazzi come potete vedere sono a mollo
Quindi pronto per voi un video super estivo
Ho deciso di rappresentare
Le diverse tipologie di ragazze quando prendono il sole
Spero tanto che il video vi piaccia...e buona visione
spero tanto che il video vi piaccia e
buona visione!
*Musica*
Maryna:- Amo... è vero che mi metti la crema?-
Ragazzo:- è la terza volta eh
Maryna:- ho capito ma se no mi brucio scusa non ci tieni alla mia pelle?
Guarda che non bisogna scottarsi eh...-
un pò più giù, un pò più a destra  un pò più a sinistra
no più su in alto, no di qua di qua di qua okay...
a posto,finito
sì, grazie
cioè mi sento che da un lato è più  in fuori dell' altro
ma è a posto Mary
no no ti prego,  guarda perchè me lo sento proprio
non voglio che mi venga il segno sbagliato
vedi !vedi! vedi che era sbagliato!
guarda che poi me la prendo con te se mi viene il segno sbagliato
ma è a posto, non ti preoccupare!
sai che sono fissata...
*Musica*
amo vieni a fare il bagno in piscina con me
arrivo...
*Maryna si accorge di non avere la parte sopra...*
*Musica*
no scusi c'è qualche problema che mi guarda da tutto il tempo?
non mi sembra sia vietato il topless qui dentro!
non lo so...!
*Musica*  *Sveglia*
*Sveglia*
no va be!
cioè mi sono messa la 50
e mi sono bruciata le ascelle!
cioè mai una gioia! questa si che è sfiga!
*Musica*
Maryna io ti consiglio di mettere  un pò di crema magari...
ma va la ma quale crema io la conosco la mia pelle
posso stare ore ed ore sotto il sole
credimi non mi sono mai bruciata!
*Risatina*
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto fatemi sapere qui sotto in un commento quale di queste tipologie siete!  come al solito se vi è piaciuto mettete mi piace iscrivetevi al canale e seguitemi su tutti gli altri social Facebook, SnapChat, Instagram e Musical.ly e mi raccomando... BACI STELLARI!!!!!!
Io vi adoro!! *Musica*
FINE CIAOOOO